first of all most people don't realize
how long it takes to learn a language hi
there this is steve kaufman from palm
springs
uh today i'm going to talk about
problems problems people have in
language learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
and they click on the bell for
notifications and if you follow me on a
podcast service uh please leave a review
so
first of all why am i talking about
problems because my whole filming setup
has
given me nothing but problems
last video i had this reflection on
those uh
prints that i have in behind me the time
before that i filmed in front of the
curtain which didn't look very nice i've
ordered some hanging sort of backdrops
but i haven't figured out how to pin
them up yet and then it'll at least look
like some fake bookshelves
um or i guess another one that's fake
wooden planks
uh but then i've ordered a little skinny
bar so that my wife can sew a little
thing and we can hang it up there and
then the lighting is all messed up and
it's not working and my
filmic pro is giving me problems so i
just got fed up with it all all my
problems
and i said i'm just going to go out in
the garden and do it
and i'm going to talk about problems
language learning problems what are the
main problems that i see amongst
language learners i'm going to try to my
center myself here again problems first
of all most people don't realize how
long it takes to learn a language so
people get frustrated they get
particularly frustrated when they get to
that first level where all of a sudden
they know a bunch of words and they
realize just how little they know of the
whole language
and people get frustrated and they have
the sense that they're not progressing
and maybe they think that everyone else
is learning and i'm not learning and i
think that's where it's so important to
realize
a that it's a long process and b that
you have to find a way of doing it that
is enjoyable so i don't worry about the
fact that i've been at arabic and
persian for a long time and there are
other people who learn faster than me
i'm enjoying it i was listening to my
egyptian arabic many stories that have
been now re-recorded by adele
of alexandria and i was going through
the texts again
and it's fun i enjoy it and i know that
trickle trickle trickle i'm improving so
the first thing i find is a lot of
people don't have the patience
second problem is a lot of people
and i find this myself too you know so
i'm doing the mini stories
adoles many stories and i've gone
through two or three of them
it's not like instantly i've done
something like i've built something or
made something happen i'm just doing
this and i have to remind myself that it
is actually slowly the language is
trickling into me so don't worry about
doing something else continue doing what
you're doing
and do as much of it as you want if you
do 15 minutes that's good if you do half
an hour's good you don't have to say i
have to do two hours a day every little
bit helps so i think
that's an important part of you know
making sure that the time you spent with
the language you don't begrudge yourself
that time you're happy doing it and if
it's 10 minutes 20 minutes half an hour
two hours it's all good
third problem people have with language
learning is they don't like to make
mistakes and therefore they are
intimidated
intimidated so you know i always stress
input but of course we all want to speak
oh most people want to speak and we want
to speak with as few mistakes as
possible of course however
i like speaking with mistakes
not that i don't want to improve but i
know
that if i speak with mistakes i'm
speaking
and i had a
conversation this morning in german i
made so many mistakes it's been so long
since i spoke german and i speak it so
seldom
and yet
in that conversation i was getting
feedback i was getting input we were
communicating if i were to do that more
my german would improve not only because
i'm speaking but also because i'm
getting input back and so
mistakes are a good thing mistakes are
not a bad thing unfortunately
too often uh the traditional language
teaching
you know instructional method
teaches us to be afraid of mistakes
well there's nothing wrong with mistakes
it's not like we're building a bridge
that we might design it wrong and the
bridge is going to collapse it's not
like that if we're communicating we're
already achieving the main goal
and if we want to improve
but we're not afraid to make mistakes
that's the ideal attitude to have so
you know you know you're speaking with
mistakes it doesn't bother you to speak
with mistakes the other person isn't
judging you but at the same time you're
listening to what they're saying you're
listening to how the language is used
you're continuing your input activities
and so you therefore are
gradually improving so i think those
would be three major problems that
language learners face in other words
they don't realize that it's a long
process number two they sometimes
begrudge themselves the time they're
spending with it three they're afraid of
making mistakes and i guess the fourth
one which kind of summarizes all those
three is they're not finding ways to
enjoy the process
they shouldn't be measuring how well
they're doing they should be saying wow
i'm enjoying what i'm doing and so
whatever however you do that because you
choose content that you like or you
activities that you like if the emphasis
is placed on enjoying the process you
will gradually improve
so just a brief chat and i realized too
and it makes me happy that many people
use my videos to work on their english
so i try to speak as clearly as possible
okay thanks for listening bye for now